hi my name is Eric vassallo I'm a recent
Angelino I think that's what you call
people live in Los Angeles I move from
San Francisco I absolutely love this
city happen to arrive in February when
this whole Oscar diversity thing became
an issue I'm an out-and-proud gay
cuban-american so for the last 15 or so
years writing screenplays I've always
tried to write non-white characters to
give my tribe a voice the script I'm
here to discuss is Neela it's a story
about 10 years in the making it was born
after watching a performance by the
Cuban ballet the world famous Cuban
Valley in Havana in this beautiful
baroque theater all gold in red velvet
and it was Cinderella which
traditionally is a white blonde female
lead role so when the female soloist the
prima ballerina came on stage the whole
audience let go subtle gasps and so did
I she was breathtaking she was perfect
she danced amazingly and she was an
afro-cuban woman and I began imagine
what her life was like dancing on that
stage and how many obstacles she had to
overcome to get to that point living
inside of this failed system this the
society that is just everything is
difficult from getting bread every day
to getting an education there are so
many things that Americans don't know
about Cuba and now with the embargo
opening up I believe it's really time
for people to to hear the stories of
these people have gone through so much
and are still going through so much even
though the countries are approaching you
know openness and a new agreement so I
do think it's relevant and I think it's
timely peace and I haven't given up on
it because I do believe it's an
important tale for Americans to see a
survival tale like this where someone
that has so little and has to struggle
so much to survive can still wear a
smile still be funny and still be so
strong and so proud and and that to me
was inspiring being not only a
cuban-american but an American we
complain a lot in this country and yeah
we we have room to improve the American
Dream does need improvement but it's
great to see this mirror of a country
that's so close to us and to see how
different they survive from day to day
so
since the story is a female-driven
suspense it's kind of like thriller
elements she gets involved with the spy
who's a sketchy journalist that happens
to be a spy and he blackmails her into
an assassination attempt by him against
the president of Cuba in Spain she's a
dancer by day and escort by night to
make her ends meet with her family she
sports her mother and her boyfriend so
it's an exciting tale it's got humor in
it and it's female-driven innocent
ultimately an empowering survivor tale
what else can I tell you as a writer
what a screenwriting taught me to really
make a screenplay stand out and shine I
believe that you have to look at it or
at least I like to imagine myself like a
sculptor and just to get like the hands
right in a marble hand you have to work
and polish it and carve it day after day
and really look at it as a process of
refinement and not just blurt it out and
maybe rewrite a couple times no it's a
constant process for it to to get to
that point where it's really shiny and
polished so I don't begrudge the process
i really enjoy each revision i go
through i enjoy suggestions for writers
out there don't write in cafes they
waste a lot of time and they increase
your a VD by exponentially you don't get
much work done and you really it's hard
to focus when you're watching people
come and go and the music and all the
things that happen in a cafe it's always
best to write at home and for me I write
better at night but it's any time I can
make time to write it's always the best
time as long as you're sitting in that
chair is the best time and eventually
you get even one page out it's it's good
you know you just gotta keep at it every
day and eventually it becomes a habit
eventually becomes an addiction
eventually becomes something that you
can't live without and you don't want to
do anything but but inevitably have to
survive you have to make money so that's
why I'm here pitching this and hopefully
i will connect with someone out there
that will believe in this story and
believe in this relevant for today and
it's an exciting really exciting tale
and i really see her on screen and i
don't want to give up on her just yet so
thank you for listening
um look out for Neela x gracias